SPEAKER: So we're just thrilled
to have Kristine McDivitt
Tompkins here with us today.
Kris is a fourth
generation Californian,
which is very cool.
I am only a first
generation Californian.
Maybe one day.
[LAUGHING]
She is from a ranching
family whose life has always
revolved around a
passion for the outdoors.
And when she was a
teenager, she worked summers
at what would become
Patagonia, Inc.
And of course, after
graduating college in Idaho,
she joined the company full
time and eventually, of course,
became their longtime CEO.
And she worked alongside
their founder, Yvon Chouinard.
And in 1994, Kris
retired and married
climber-entrepreneur
Douglas Tompkins.
He was the founder of North Face
and the co-founder of Esprit.
And working together,
Kris and Doug
achieved some really
incredible results
in the creation
of national parks.
And as you may know, just
on January 29 of this year,
Kristine and Chilean
President Michelle Bachelet
joined forces to create
five new national parks
and expanded three
others, adding
a total of 10 million
acres of new national park
land in Chile, which
is truly remarkable.
Yes.
[APPLAUSE]
Cheers to that.
So of course, truly an
incredible achievement
amongst many throughout
your great career,
so we're really thrilled
to have you here today.
KRISTINE MCDIVITT
TOMPKINS: Thank you.
SPEAKER: Let's dive in.
KRISTINE MCDIVITT TOMPKINS:
All right, well, I
thought I would take all of
you on a very fast tour of some
of our work.
I think I have 10,
15 minutes that I
can talk to you straight up.
I'm going to get out of this
chair and move it to the side.
SPEAKER: I'm going
to leave you up here
and I'll come back for a chat.
KRISTINE MCDIVITT
TOMPKINS: All right.
I thought the best way to
do this today is give you
a little bit of background
of Doug and me and how--
why was it that we
started out in business
and ended up where
we did, working
in the Southern Cone in
conservation and other areas.
So I'm going to start off with
a little video that places you
where we are as of
the last 60 days.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
- It's the biggest deal
of its kind in history.
This is an unbelievable
opportunity
for conservation and for Chile.
[END PLAYBACK]
KRISTINE MCDIVITT
TOMPKINS: There we go.
So--
[APPLAUSE]
--how did we get
going on this path?
And I thought I would put
this picture up of Doug
and me back in the day in
the '60s, '70s, and '80s.
Both of us were
climbers, ski racers.
And through that
life, we obviously
developed a great
love for the things
seen and unseen about
the natural world
and really just a
world and a commitment
of having a wild life.
Also, you guys are
probably too young,
but I'm sure you've seen
photographs of the '60s.
And we were
definitely influenced
by the activism that
sprang out of that decade
and ran into the '70s.
And it became one of the clarion
calls to our personal lives.
And surely, some of you have
been moved by these things,
as well.
That kind of ethos,
that kind of direction,
really was one of the reasons
that the three companies
that we're associated with
developed the kind of ethos
that they did.
And of course, Doug
with The North Face
and Esprit and Yvon
Chouinard, whom
I worked for for a
total of 25 years or so,
they had different
products, but absolutely
a long list of things in common.
In 1993, Doug had already
sold his portion of Esprit,
and I was getting very itchy
as the CEO of Patagonia.
I felt like I wanted
to do something else,
but I wasn't quite
sure what it is.
And then, Doug Tompkins
drifted into my life.
And he had put more
thought and longer thought
into how might we
commit ourselves
to the things we love in the
third stage of our lives.
And that ended up forming
family foundations
and basing ourselves out
of Chile and Argentina
between the United
States, focused
on building these big projects.
So our foundation is
based on five areas.
Conservation is probably the one
that we're most well known for.
That's the conservation of
landscape and marine systems.
And we'll talk a little
bit about that at the end.
Restoration-- the
restoration of forest,
the restoration of grasslands,
the restoration of our minds,
but also, the restoration
of extirpated species
wherever we're working.
What is missing?
And we're going to
talk a little bit
about that in a few minutes.
But re-wilding, the
idea of bringing back
species to those areas
where they had gone missing
became easily half
of our work today.
Regenerative
agriculture-- as Doug
always says, if you don't
get agriculture right,
you can kiss off the
rest because agriculture
is the greatest use
of terrestrial earth.
It is unconventional
ag, toxic to the soils.
We could talk about erosion
and all sorts of things that
are happening today and for
the last 100 years in ag,
but we are very active there.
And finally, activism.
As Ed Abbey said,
"Sentiment without action
is the ruin of the soul."
So unlike a lot of
conservation groups,
we take activism
very, very seriously.
We believe that if
you see something
that is going and trending
in the wrong direction
toward your values,
that you need
to stand up and shake the tree.
So finally healthy,
dignified human communities.
We have a saying, "economic
development as a consequence
of conservation."
So where we work, we're
not finished with our work
until local communities,
provincial communities,
and in some cases, the
national political scene,
can benefit from the very
things that we're working on.
And that's very long-term work,
but very satisfying and a must.
So off we went.
We based ourselves
outside of Pumalín Park.
This is in 1993.
Big change from running
Patagonia and swirling
around the world.
And that's where we ended up.
This is the farm where we were
based when we were working
on Pumalín.
And it's a roadless
area, one of two only
between Fairbanks, Alaska,
and the tip of South America.
And we were planted in
the middle of one of them.
Big change.
Over the ensuing years, we began
to put teams together and build
a kind of mental
architecture for what
could happen in these
regions, in terms
of conservation and working on
the other goals that we have.
In the ensuing years,
this is what we've done.
We have 13 national parks and
just over 13 million acres
that we have put in to
permanent conservation
in the form of a national park.
That's what those teams
have been working on.
We have a team here
in San Francisco.
We have one in Chile, of
course, and one in Argentina.
So why national parks?
When we think
about conservation,
we get asked that
question a lot.
Why didn't we just buy
the land, put a big lock
on the gate out in front,
and leave it alone?
And for us, first
of all, we grew up
in the national park system
of the United States,
which is a big part
of our culture.
You don't think about it so
often, but there they are.
And if you took them away
in the United States,
you'd find yourself lacking.
You'd find yourself wanting
them back and defending
those national parks.
They create a kind of
image for a country
that helps define who
we are as a nation.
But more importantly, we look
at it as a democratic move.
If we close off this,
the millions of acres
that we acquired,
and nobody comes in,
it's like owning a
Picasso and you hang it
in your living room.
And you and your family can look
at it and maybe some friends,
but that's it.
If you hang it at MoMA,
millions of people
can see that Picasso every year.
And that, to us, is essential,
that access, trails,
all the things that go in with
national parks are available.
So I'm going to take you
on a very, very speedy tour
through three of our parks that
each have a different ecotype.
So starting, Pumalín, as you
can see the little white box.
It's on the Pacific
coast in Southern Chile.
It's the first park
we ever worked on.
And it goes from
the Andes at the top
of the Argentine border,
through 800,000 acres of forest,
and down to the Pacific Ocean.
We were famously called the
couple who cut Chile in half
when we first got going.
And we were called a
lot of other things,
too, but I won't go into that.
So this park is just
over a million acres
and just declared
a national park
in February 27 of this year.
The alerce trees-- there
are 30% of the last stand
of alerce trees in this
park, a first cousin
to the giant sequoias
here in California.
A lot of flora and fauna.
It's an impenetrable
forest, which has probably
been a benefit for it because,
otherwise, a lot more of it
would have been cut.
It's also just an exquisitely
beautiful, wild place.
And we have our own volcano
that went off in 2008
and created tremendous
havoc for us in cleaning it
up and reforming.
Architecture in all of our parks
are always connected to place,
so you never go to a
park that we've worked on
and find the same
style of architecture.
In this case, it's a
Chilotan wooden style
reflected in bridges,
reflected in everything we do.
So forests, rain
forests, and now we
move south to Patagonia
National Park.
And we actually have one of the
longtime founder-types sitting
in the back row back there.
This was started in 2004.
It goes from the edge
of the northern ice
cap in southern Aysen
and has the Baker River
as its Western edge.
And it's roughly--
well, no, not roughly--
764,000 acres, much
of which is grassland.
It's considered to be one of the
biggest grassland restoration
projects in the
world, but I never
trust those kinds of statements.
So I just say it's
one of the biggest.
It's beautiful.
It's emblematic.
And it crosses the border--
it goes to the border.
And what you're looking out
from the border in this shot
is Patagonia National
Park in Argentina.
They're not yet contiguous, but
that would be a wonderful dream
to have them touch one another.
Lots of animals there, some
you recognize, some you won't.
This little guy is coming
back from having been
almost extincted from the area.
So you have all these
little kinds of victories--
predators like mountain
lions coming back
once you stop persecuting
them, bird life.
Everything begins to come
back as you take, in our case,
50,000 head of livestock
off this former ranch
and take all the
fences out, which
was nearly 500
miles of fence line,
and you see the region begins
to heal itself with lots
of visitors every year.
And this, too, was just
made a national park
at the end of
January of this year.
A lot of wildlife
work in this park.
Pumas are coming back.
You have a deer nearly extinct.
And this is a long
story, but I will just
tell you that I have often
found that the easiest
thing we've done is
actually acquire the land.
And the minute the ink
is dry on the check,
projects like this arise,
as they rightfully should,
and they become the
challenges and headaches
and you hope a few
successes as you go along
in creating these
big protected areas.
These are not guns.
They're dart rifles,
and just to show you
a little bit about how
much work there is to do,
besides creating just
the infrastructure
and acquiring the land.
Another species reintroduction
here up on the border.
And you can see the architecture
for this park reflects
Patagonia.
It's actually an
English-style that
was settled by the English
who came to Argentina
and built the
railroads in the 1800s.
And of course, any good
park has campgrounds,
has trails, and so on.
And this is no exception.
This I put in here because
this is an example of activism.
There was a--
I won't go into the
whole story, but there
was a move to dam two of Chile's
most pristine and beautiful
rivers.
It was an eight-year
fight, millions
of dollars spent, many, many
NGOs working against it,
and truly, David and
Goliath, and finally, we won.
And those rivers run free.
So activism attached
to conservation, never
leave it far behind,
in my opinion.
The third one,
Iberá National Park,
1.7 million acres in the
Northeast eastern section
of Argentina, so cross
the border and go north.
This is wetlands and
savanna grasslands.
It's hot, subtropical.
When we first visited there,
got out of the plane and said,
let's get back in the plane.
It's too hot here.
There are bugs, and it's flat.
And Doug insisted
and came back quietly
and bought it a month later,
the first piece of property
we started with.
Because this is what he saw--
I missed it somehow--
the tremendous biodiversity,
an area that nobody really
knew that the province had.
It was sort of
like no man's land.
And we've come a
long way since 1997.
And it is now a national park.
So just some pictures
of what is there,
but then what is missing?
Within five years of
having arrived there,
we began to realize that
species who were missing
had to be dealt with.
You had to actively
figure out how
to bring them back,
which in Latin America
was really unheard of,
and most of the Americas.
The jaguars were missing.
Giant anteaters were missing.
Tapirs were missing.
Green-shouldered macaws missing.
And so we committed ourselves
over the last 14 years
to start bringing them back.
And all of the species
that you just saw
have been brought back with
the exception of the jaguar.
We have adult jaguars, but
you can't release them, which
is another talk altogether.
But suffice to say, where
there is someone missing,
we have committed that where
we work, by the time we leave,
they will be back.
So just a few shots
of what this entails,
working with the jaguars at
the jaguar breeding center,
and so on.
So as we roll out of those
projects, we're still--
we are an ongoing team working
on new projects, one of which
is in marine conservation.
These are the first two
marine national parks
of Argentina, something we
started just over a year ago.
So lots to talk about.
But I'm going to leave
it there, because I
think it's more engaging if
we get a very fast overview
and then start to visit.
A lot of people ask
us why do we do this.
We could just buy yachts
and go lay on the beach.
Well, this is one
of the reasons.
And this little guy, certainly
top choice, and generations
of humans in the future.
We can't imagine that
it's ethical to leave
for future generations a mess,
which is the course we're on.
And as Jane Goodall
says, "We are stealing
from our children's futures."
And so how do we work
against that trend?
That's really the
question mark upon us.
So thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
I'll grab my chair back.
SPEAKER: All right.
Thank you so much, Kris.
That was such a
fabulous presentation
and such beautiful photography.
KRISTINE MCDIVITT
TOMPKINS: It was fast.
SPEAKER: Yeah, yes.
KRISTINE MCDIVITT
TOMPKINS: Quick trip.
SPEAKER: And now, we'll get
to dig in a little bit more,
so this will be perfect.
KRISTINE MCDIVITT
TOMPKINS: Good.
SPEAKER: So before we go
back to South America,
I wanted to bring you
back to California.
You know, we mentioned that
you're a fourth generation
Californian, so I'd love
to have you just start
from the beginning, telling us
a little bit about how you grew
up and kind of where your
passion for the environment
and conservation
really springs from.
KRISTINE MCDIVITT TOMPKINS:
Well, as you said,
I grew up on a ranch where my
great grandfather-- he founded
it.
And my grandfather
was born there.
Our father was born there.
We were born there.
So we were sort of hooligans,
as ranching kids often are,
and outside a lot.
But I don't think that my
sensibilities toward nature
really started there.
Maybe it made me more
comfortable in it.
We moved to Venezuela when I was
eight years old for three years
and then came out of there.
And that was probably
the first time
that I was exposed to so many
species that, as a Californian,
you'd never see.
And they were right there.
It was not in Caracas.
We were way out in
the Orinoco Basin.
I don't know.
I think Yvon had a
huge impact on my life.
I met him when I was 15.
And once you get into
the climbing tribe,
I don't think-- it's
like Hotel California.
You never leave.
[CHUCKLING]
And I would credit
Yvon with a lot
of what's happened in my life.
My family was more traditional.
And the ladies wore pearls
and not climbing ropes.
So I think that he had
a lot to do with that.
SPEAKER: Yeah, and I'd love
to hear more about that.
That's what I was
going to ask you next.
It sounds like you
guys met climbing,
but I'd love to hear more
about how you guys connected
and then, ultimately, what
brought you to Patagonia
and how you ended
up as the CEO there.
KRISTINE MCDIVITT
TOMPKINS: Well, I
was supposed to go to a
girls boarding school.
And I swore to my
mother I wouldn't go.
So I went to the local high
school and then realized I
didn't--
I don't know.
Anyway, Yvon was
renting the house next
to our family's beach house.
And there were a lot of
climbers around quite a bit.
I had an older brother who was
sort of in with that crowd.
And I was 15--
artists-- and in the
absence of a pull
toward my own age at
the local high school,
I started hanging out with them.
And then, after my
first year in college,
my mother informed me during
the front end of summer
that, contrary to
my personal belief,
she was not my personal banker--
[CHUCKLING]
--and that I needed
to get a job.
So I was worried.
I didn't know how
to do anything.
And so Yvon all said, why
don't you come work for me?
So I did.
There were six people there,
just technical rock and ice
climbing equipment.
And so we all wore
bathing suits to work.
And I would peel the
labels off carabiners
from Germany or package things.
And then for every summer
after that, it was a default.
And then, when I
graduated from college,
I had no idea what
I was going to do.
And our family is very strict.
The minute that your degree
touches the end of this finger,
you're on your own.
There's like a French guillotine
coming down, which was fine.
We understood that.
But I had no idea what
I was going to do.
And so I just started
working for Yvon
full time, something I've
never regretted, obviously.
You know, it was
all pretty organic.
I think it's very different now
when you graduate from college.
In your studies, you
have a direction.
You have a-- you're
going somewhere.
And in our family, you just
needed to go to college.
Nobody really talked
too much about what
you needed to do after
that or preparing for that.
And then, a year--
let's see, I was 22.
So when I was 23,
Yvon decided, I'd
like to make some clothing
for climbers, for all of us.
And that's how it got going
and that's how it is now.
SPEAKER: Yeah.
And then, what did your
trajectory there look like?
How did you go from labels off
carabiners to being the CEO?
KRISTINE MCDIVITT
TOMPKINS: Oh, you know,
it was so small,
starting at zero.
And you did everything--
shipper, hand
labeling our little tiny
early catalogs out to whomever
had requested one.
And I like running things.
I mean, I see that now.
I don't think I knew it then.
But I think I just naturally
expanded what I was doing.
And Yvon loves
working with women.
He really-- he's very--
I won't say biased
in that direction--
but he's cognizant of that
and a lot of trust in me
and also Malinda
Chouinard, his wife.
So if I was given
something to do,
I would grab onto it and I
wouldn't-- it's like a bone
for a dog.
I grabbed it and I
didn't give it back.
Maybe that's how.
But I loved it.
And I have a kind of
endless pit for taking
on stuff that's
especially difficult
or things that I didn't
know about heretofore.
SPEAKER: Yeah, yeah, absolutely.
And one thing I was particularly
curious to ask you about--
for me, I am such an admirer
and I'm sure many other people
in the room of Patagonia's
commitment to sustainability
and how that seems
like it's such a--
[CLEARS THROAT]
--excuse me-- core value of the
company through the products,
through a lot of the campaigns
the company has funded.
I'd love to hear you talk more
about how that ethos began
and how you guys really saw
that as tied to the business
because it seems like it
really always has been.
KRISTINE MCDIVITT TOMPKINS:
Oh, it's absolutely
Yvon and Melinda Chouinard.
Absolutely.
If you pull a string
in anything that you
would find inside
the company today,
that string will lead
back to one of them,
whether it's child care
and Malinda's insistence
that we build that
population into our planning.
The understanding of
the ecological crisis
in the mid '70s, absolutely,
they both were there at a time
when I had no idea.
Rose Marcario, the
CEO of Patagonia,
is absolutely imbued and
very, very aggressive
about the company taking
a lead, whether it's
sustainability, or fighting
for Bears Ears, public lands,
you name it.
The company is really
on the front lines.
And I think that's
the value system
that we've had
since the beginning,
but it's absolutely clear.
I just came from a two-day
Patagonia board meeting.
And it's full of these
discussions about,
how do you keep pushing the line
out, asking more of yourself,
asking more of customers,
in terms of educating them,
and will they join us as
the lawsuit was placed
against the government having to
do with public lands and Bears
Ears?
And the response to those
things has been extraordinary.
So they still run the
company as a means
to build the greatest
products, which has always
been Yvon's desire, but also
to use the company absolutely
as a mechanism to
change the world.
And that has-- if I close
my eyes at a board meeting
and I listen to
Yvon speak, it could
have been 45 years ago
when we got going together.
He is very consistent.
And I think that's just an
extraordinary and unusual set
of circumstances.
SPEAKER: Yeah, absolutely.
So you talked a little
bit in your introduction
about how meeting Doug Tompkins
had this big influence on you
and the next phase
in your career.
I would love to hear you
talk a little bit more
about that-- about
how you guys connected
and sort of what led you
to make this transition
into conservation.
KRISTINE MCDIVITT TOMPKINS:
I'll tell you part of the story.
SPEAKER: All right.
[LAUGHING]
KRISTINE MCDIVITT TOMPKINS:
I met Doug when I was 19.
He was a climbing partner and
a very good friend of Yvon's.
And he was a climbing partner
of my former husband's, as well.
So the climbing community
is kind of small.
Certainly back then,
it was a lot smaller.
And I knew him since
I was 19 and knew him
during the Esprit days.
And then, we sort of
lost track of each other.
And then, I was down
in southern Argentina
with Yvon and a few other
people eating dinner
in this three dog town and
in walks Doug Tompkins.
And that's where it started,
so it would have been 1990,
I think.
And then, it was
like an algae bloom.
[CHUCKLING]
SPEAKER: And was he--
were either of you already
working in conservation
or was it just really
an extension of--
KRISTINE MCDIVITT
TOMPKINS: So yeah, Doug
was looking at the first
piece of property--
SPEAKER: OK.
KRISTINE MCDIVITT
TOMPKINS: --second.
Yeah, so he was on his way--
SPEAKER: Yeah, and what--
KRISTINE MCDIVITT
TOMPKINS: --in Argentina.
SPEAKER: Yeah, and what made
you decide at that moment
that you wanted to make this
shift from having impact
in the business world
through having impact
through your new work?
KRISTINE MCDIVITT
TOMPKINS: Oh, well, love
had a lot to do with it--
SPEAKER: Yeah?
KRISTINE MCDIVITT
TOMPKINS: --you know.
If everything is built
on that kind of love,
then we'd be in great shape.
SPEAKER: Absolutely.
KRISTINE MCDIVITT
TOMPKINS: Timing.
I think timing in life is really
40% of what happens to you,
good and bad.
We sort of got
together at a time
when I really wanted
to do something else.
I had started working with
Yvon when I was so young.
And I was 40 years old.
And I began to panic
that I would be there
when I'm 50 and
60, maybe even 70,
which is where I'm headed now.
And I didn't know
what it would be,
but I also thought
that the company would
benefit from new leadership.
And so the timing
was perfect, really.
That's how it happened.
SPEAKER: And obviously,
you've already
shared with us a little
bit about the huge impact
that you guys have made through
conservation and your work.
I was curious to hear you just
talk a little bit about what's
your feeling about
the status of land
conservation in general today?
How are we doing?
Are we doing enough
quickly enough?
KRISTINE MCDIVITT TOMPKINS:
Well, the obvious answer,
are we doing enough,
using the royal we--
SPEAKER: Yeah, right,
exactly-- collectively.
KRISTINE MCDIVITT
TOMPKINS: Collectively no.
I think, if you look at
just the raw numbers of area
protected or even in transition
versus the conversion
of the natural
world to production,
we're definitely
on the losing team.
So I think that to use a
terrible militaristic metaphor,
there is an army
out there of people
who don't want to see the
effects of climate change play
all the way out.
There are millions of people out
there who really still believe
that development has to be
in balance with conservation,
however that takes place.
And no, we're not
moving fast enough.
We can look at these numbers
that Tompkins Conservation may
be involved in,
but when you look
at the tsunami that's coming
in, then it feels quite small.
Yeah.
SPEAKER: And can you
talk a little bit more
about how you guys
ended up choosing
Latin America as your
focus area for your work?
KRISTINE MCDIVITT TOMPKINS:
Really, it started with Doug.
He was a ski racer, as I was.
And he used to train in
the off-seasons in Chile
and Argentina, as all the
teams did in those days.
And he had no money, so he
would hitchhike around Chile
and Argentina every season.
And that's how he began
to know the countries.
And he really fell
in love with them.
And then, in 1968, he talked
Yvon in, in two weeks,
to drive from San Francisco
to the tip of South
America surfing, climbing,
skiing off of volcanoes,
and with the goal of climbing
this emblematic peak called
Fitz Roy in southern Argentina.
And they did.
And they were gone six months.
And they did everything
they had planned to do.
And when it was all
over, they sold the van
they'd driven down in and
came back to California.
And it really set
something in their minds
about this place, which
in 1968 was really
kind of like a phantom, this
romantic, wild place on earth
that nobody really
knew anything about.
And then, Yvon,
five years later,
decides he wants to
start making clothes
and he settled on
Patagonia as the name.
So when Doug started looking
around to see where he would
work, at least
one of the areas--
because at the same time
we're doing all this,
we're doing other
things, as well,
that aren't necessarily
directed at the Southern Cone.
But the conservation side, he
just always had this affinity
toward it since he got started.
So that's really the nut of it.
SPEAKER: Well, that makes sense.
And of course, we talked about
the incredible announcement
in January of the
10 million acres.
And you started to say a little
bit about marine conservation
is sort of a next frontier.
I'd love to hear
you talk about where
do you want to go from here.
I know you've already
achieved so much.
But what's sort
of on the horizon?
KRISTINE MCDIVITT
TOMPKINS: Well, I'm
definitely interested in
marine protected areas.
And I don't really see us
moving out of the Southern Cone.
That's for one thing.
Because we're a small team.
And I feel like it's really
important that we build off
of what we've done so far and
not just go to some new place
and start from zero again,
because there's still
so many things that we
could do in conjunction
with the various governments,
and the two countries,
and building off of those
relationships, and so on.
So the marine area,
our big vision
is going around Cape Horn.
It is one of--
it's a convergence,
a marine convergence,
between the Pacific Ocean
and the Atlantic Ocean.
So that's where we're
especially interested.
You know, these are just ideas.
There are a lot of people
working in the marine area
down in Chile, not
so much in Argentina.
I think that it's
important to talk
with the leaders of the
sovereign states and ask them,
are there areas
where we might be
of service to the goals of
the government and so on?
And then, of course,
there are always
projects that are on
the terrestrial side
and the agricultural side.
Although, that's a little--
that takes place out
of our family life
and not inside the foundations.
So I don't have any
intention of doing
anything else until I fly away.
So I feel blessed to be
doing what we're doing,
especially blessed that
we have the teams we have.
I know many times, it's sort
of the Doug and Kris show,
but that isn't it at all.
We have so many people who've
been with us for so many years.
And in Chile, these parks
have been built and created
by Chileans.
And the same can be said
for those in Argentina.
So I always need
to remind people
that we wouldn't have
gotten off first base
without a tremendous amount
of work and dedication
on that side.
And I think that, as
far as we've seen,
we're all in to keep going.
SPEAKER: That's so wonderful.
So I know you--
I really like the title that
you gave your talk today
of paying rent to the earth.
So I was so curious to hear you
talk a little bit about what
does that mean to you and
how does that relate the work
that you do.
KRISTINE MCDIVITT
TOMPKINS: I don't
know who coined that pay your
rent for living on the planet.
I don't know if it was
Yvon or Doug or both or--
I'm not sure.
But it's absolutely true.
I think, regardless of
where you are in your life,
you're working at Google,
you're working at Patagonia,
you're working for yourself,
you're not working at all,
it's impossible--
one of the reasons
we're stuck where we are
is that we, as humans,
have separated ourselves
from the fact that we're
dependent on the natural world.
So I think that
the big challenge
is, how do you use every
asset of your personal life
toward changing that trend?
That's really the question.
SPEAKER: Yeah.
KRISTINE MCDIVITT TOMPKINS:
And so when I say assets,
I think where you
work is an asset, what
your personal strengths
are are your assets, how
you use your spare time
is an asset that you have.
And I think paying your rent
for living on the planet
is a very--
it sounds superficial, but
it's actually quite deep
if you adopt it--
that I will do
something every day
that has nothing
to do with myself
and that's how I'm going to
get out of bed every day.
And it's a slogan in
a certain kind of way,
but it's an important
one because we
have to live our lives
with intention to the best
that we can.
And it's hard, because we
live in a culture that's
going in the other direction.
We're valued by our
financial means.
The values, the criteria,
by which we're measured
don't really reinforce pay your
rent for living on the planet.
So people have to
discard or roll back
the importance of
some of the criteria
that we've placed on
ourselves and take
an independent decision to
live your life differently
or a little
differently, at least.
Nobody's a saint here.
We're all swimming in
this sea of contradictions
that we face-- climate change
and these other facts that
are very clear to us.
And yet, we have tremendous
technology at our touch.
We have tremendous opportunities
to move around and see
parts of the world we
wouldn't have otherwise.
And somehow, we have to find
a real balance between those
things or we're--
as Jane says, we're
stealing the future
from those who come after us in
the human and non-human world.
So that's what it means.
SPEAKER: Yeah, yeah.
And you really just
touched upon the value
of an individual action.
What advice do you
give people who say,
I don't know where to start?
I want to have a
positive impact,
but I don't know where to begin.
How do you advise people
to get more engaged?
KRISTINE MCDIVITT
TOMPKINS: Well, I
used to speak at a lot
of business schools.
And always, the day
would end like this--
what would you do
if you were us?
And I always say the same thing.
When I was your age, we didn't
know what we know today,
so I had it a lot easier
than you guys have.
The problem is, once
you know what you know,
then you can't turn
your back on that.
And so this is a really
simplistic answer
to your question, but I do
believe that most of life
is intention.
It is not difficult to decide
what you personally will do.
You have to decide that
you're going to do something
or hopefully plural some things.
And then, go out and find
out what should you be doing.
You can make
donations to places.
And they should be
well-thought through.
Are these groups who are really
active and willing to push
the boundaries of
what's taking place now?
Or you can go out
and chain yourself
to the heavy equipment--
I don't know what you
call those things--
and stop big trees from being
plowed down in the Sierra.
The point is to act.
The point is to
participate in a way that
reflects your own values all
the time-- not all the time,
but every day something.
Because that's the problem.
I think we all get
stuck on, what can I do?
What should be my first step?
The first step is just
getting out of bed and saying,
this is where I'm headed.
And if I don't know who it is
or where it is or what it is,
I'm going to find out.
I'm going to try
to figure out what
are the root causes of where
we find ourselves, which most
of us are really not clear on.
And I would include
myself in that category
several years ago.
If you don't understand
how we got here,
you can't really
understand what it
takes to mitigate those things
that have been so horribly
destructive in the last
couple hundred years
or however you
want to measure it.
I studied the collapse of
civilizations as an avocation
because I keep trying to
understand, why would we
do this over and over
and over again, when,
as Jared Diamond would say,
the pattern of civil collapse
is so repetitive?
So what is it about
us that we can't
move against those trends?
Or do we just to
abdicate and say, well,
this is human nature;
we'll spiral up and out,
and then evolve again?
But I say, I don't
think that's--
I don't think that's
the way to go about it.
You should try to fight
against those things that
are triggers for this
toward the destruction
of the natural world and
the greatest extinction
crisis in history.
And especially, when
you start learning
about the stakes of the marine
systems, it's bloody desperate.
So that's a choice.
We have to make a choice.
And it doesn't mean you
run off and live in a cave,
but it does mean that you
have to take a stand somewhere
along the trajectory
of our daily lives.
SPEAKER: Absolutely.
That's wonderful advice.
Well, I know we have
about 10 minutes left.
And I'm sure people
in the audience
are eager to ask
Kris their questions.
So we have a microphone
here in the center aisle,
so please feel free to come on
up and share your questions.
AUDIENCE: Hi, Kris.
thank you so much for coming
and speaking to Google.
I know that there's
a lot of inspiration
around the idea of
protecting half of the earth.
And I wanted to get
your thoughts on that.
KRISTINE MCDIVITT TOMPKINS: Yes.
We just met with Dr.
EO Wilson 10 days ago,
who originated the
concept of Half Earth.
And then there's
nature needs half
and there are various
versions of this.
So we all get stuck in,
well, OK, then Half Earth,
so which half?
And how would that happen?
So we immediately
set up roadblocks,
because it would be insanely
difficult to do that.
However, I think what he's
trying to say and move toward
is this--
that for healthy ecosystems
for human and non-human life,
as a rough estimate,
half of the earth
needs to be very well cared
for, maybe not completely
without some production
in it, but it
has to be really managed, or
systems begin to collapse,
as they are in the
oceans and so on.
So I think that it's a bold
way to describe the necessity
to move forward from
where we are now to where
we need to get to in 50 years.
What should we look like
at the end of this century?
I think, for me, it's a
better way to look at this.
And when you have a
circumstance where
you have rising human
population base,
you have a rising
consumption level,
and you have a
falling resource base,
so somewhere, if you
just do the math,
you have this inherent conflict
that we're speeding toward.
And it has different
manifestations,
whether it's climate
change or other big moves,
the extinction
crisis, and so on.
So I think that, yes, the
conversation of Half Earth
needs to be on the table.
How do you execute that and how
do you move just intellectually
toward that is a challenge.
It's not simple, but
it's probably real.
I think it's real.
And I think that we--
as these crises begin to
mount, whether they're
through climate change
and other factors,
society will move toward
that by necessity.
So it's not all going to
be volunteer or voluntary,
but it will be
something like that.
It's a lot to wrap
your head around.
It's a lot for me to
wrap around my head.
But my instincts tell
me that our way of life,
imagining there are
no limits to growth,
there are no limits to
the things that we want
and that we can do, is truly
a fabrication of false hope.
It's not true.
I don't believe it.
I don't think
anybody who's really
thought about the possibility
of economic growth--
infinite economic
growth-- is possible.
And I know there are bazillions
of conversations about this.
And I don't pretend to
have the final answer.
But I do know that these
are things that individuals,
companies, everybody
needs to be talking about,
instead of sitting
on them as if there's
some sort of deep secret
that nobody wants to face.
Then, as in all things, that
will knock you off your chair.
AUDIENCE: Thanks
for coming today.
Congrats on 10 million acres.
That's a big number.
What do you consider the
essential pieces of that
really coming to reality?
And if you had to
counsel groups,
such as yourselves,
that were getting
started in other
places in the world,
and things that come to mind
are, how does the president
balance all the influences
on then business development
growth with preserving nature?
What were the hard parts?
How did you solve them?
And how would you advise
others in your shoes?
KRISTINE MCDIVITT
TOMPKINS: Well, first
of all, which is
the most nebulous,
and I apologize
for this, but there
are moments when things
like this at this scale
can take place.
And there are other moments
when the stars aren't lined up
and the circumstances are
not there for you to do it.
So that's a piece of it.
And it's not a small piece.
But as we see, even in the
United States now, leadership
and how it looks at
conservation protected areas,
whether they're parks or
monuments, and the idea
of public lands in general,
varies from administration
to administration.
So it is a matter of
picking your moment.
And it is a matter of
really tying the economics
for the regions that
these parks are located,
that the economic development
long term is actually
probably best suited to
be tied to, in this case,
a national park, and as
I said at the beginning,
economic development as a
consequence of conservation.
And a really good
way to look at this
is if you see the
country of Botswana--
15 years, 25 years ago, Botswana
had a big kind of vision plan
for their country.
And it involved mining
and all sorts of things.
But then, starting with
the Okavango, of course,
it began to see that
tourism was changing
the story for many
local economies
and it doesn't show
any sign of shrinking.
In fact, it's growing.
So we were able to work
with Chilean leadership
in creating these
parks as a master
plan for economic development.
It is not true--
I don't know of any
case where countries
who have developed
national parks
have kicked the bejesus
out of their ability
to grow economically.
It is a myth that company--
excuse me, that's
a Freudian slip--
countries have to choose
one way or the other.
It's just not true.
If I was leading a country,
which I never will,
you need to do both.
If you're an
inspired leader, you
have the courage
to insist on both.
And this, I think,
was the motivation
for President Bachelet
because, mark my words,
anybody can have a great
idea, but you will not achieve
that great idea unless--
especially at a large
scale-- unless you
have true partnerships who
will go the distance with you.
And in this case, President
Bachelet and her ministers
were absolutely the
reason this happened.
I mean, we couldn't
have done it on our own
because we don't
make national parks.
We don't designate them, I mean.
So if somebody wants
to start something,
whether it's here, wherever
it is, to your question,
you have to decide what it
is you're trying to save.
You have to know
that area like crazy.
You need to map it.
You need to think about it.
You need to walk across it.
You need to know who
your neighbors are.
You need to know
if the country--
if this would be an asset
for the country overall.
It's just like building
any big project.
You have to do a
lot of groundwork
first and then take
your first step.
But before that, you
have to love these areas.
Whatever it is, you
better love them.
And it better be a deep love
because these things are not
simple.
And you have to be willing to
be unpopular sometimes and hold
hopes and dreams
for your land trust
or whatever it is that
will be challenged.
And people will find you're an
intrusion on the development
of the economy and so on.
So you have to stay the course.
That's another point
of advice I'd give you.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
KRISTINE MCDIVITT TOMPKINS:
But I hope you do it.
[LAUGHING]
SPEAKER: Well, I
think we're going
to need to leave it there.
Kris, thank you so much again.
This has just been tremendous.
[APPLAUSE]
KRISTINE MCDIVITT
TOMPKINS: Thank you, guys.
And thank you, Google.
SPEAKER: Yeah, absolutely.
KRISTINE MCDIVITT TOMPKINS: We
use Google, not on the hour,
on the five minutes.
So thank you very much for
making our lives much easier.
And I hope that Google, through
its enormous expanse of contact
in the world, takes
Mother Earth along with it
and does what it can with
this unbelievable population
of people whom you have.
And charge yourselves
and the company
with seeing, that
100 years from now,
we have healthy ecosystems
and healthy, dignified human
populations.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]